هذه ليست الجبهه الوحيده التي يريد بوتين
تخطي عقباتها فجبهه لخلق وجمع الحلفاء
ليست موهبه الطريق كما تقول التصريحات
القادمه من الشرق
مدفوعه بتعقد الموقف في حرب اوكرانيا تسعى
موسكو الى تشكيل تحالف يضم الصين والهند
سعي تقيده العلاقات المتازمه بين القوتين
العالميتين بسبب الصراع الحدودي المستمر
بينهما منذ عقود
الصين تريد ان تظل روسيا الى جانبها من
اجل عالم متعدد الاقطاب بينما تحاول الهند
امساك العصا من المنتصف
هذه الحقبه ليست وقتا للحرب فالديمقراطيه
والحوار والدبلوماسيه هي سبل المضي قدما
بكين ومنذ ان بدات روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا قدمت دعم اقتصاديا ودبلوماسيا
حاسما لموسكو واشترت منتجات الطاقه
الروسيه واتهمت واشنطن والنيتو بتهيئه
الظروف التي ادت الى الغزو الروسي
وفقا لصحيفه وول ستريت جورنال فان مخاوف
القياده الصينيه تتزايد جراء الدعم
العسكري الغربي لاوكرانيا والذي سيضعف
روسيا شريكها السياسي الرئيسي
وتشير سجلات الجمارك الروسيه هذا الشهر
الى ان الصين تقوم في المقابل بشحن معدات
الملاحه وتكنولوجيا التشويش وقطع غيار
المقاتلات الى روسيا
نود ان نؤكد مره اخرى على ان الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين روسيا والصين لم توجه
ابدا ضد طرف ثالث وايضا لا تخضع للتدخل
والاستفزاز من قبل اي طرف ثالث والاكثر من
ذلك لن يطغى عليها الاكراه والضغط من
اطراف ثالثه
تقول الصحيفه ان مقاومه اوكرانيا القويه
في ساحه المعركه دفعت بكين الى اعاده
التفكير وجعلها اكثر ميلا للضغط من اجل
وقف اطلاق النار لمنع المزيد من
الانتكاسات الروسيه او حتى هزيمه على نطاق
واسع تفكير قد يضع حدا للحرب وتداعياتها